hello sir my name is Samuel leaves and
in this video I'm gonna be explaining Co
deal sourcing
what is Co people sourcing you might
have heard the term family lounge Co do
the sourcing is very simple firstly I
need to define deal sourcing once I've
defined deal sourcing I can then define
co-sourcing or code deal sourcing deals
sourcing is when you find a deal you
source it you package it and you sell it
to an investor deal packaging deal
sourcing deals selling it's an extremely
lucrative investment strategy because
even though you're not investing in the
property yourself you're investing your
time in defining the property and you
can do this with very little money to
package and sell a deal all you need is
a deal
you need investors you need a reputation
and you need a business that is
compliant where you can legally sell a
deal through that company very lucrative
many of my students package and sell
deals without owning property and make
tens of thousands of pounds per month
I myself have packaged and sold hundreds
of property investment deals never owned
them never paid for them just passed
them on and the average fee that you'll
get from an investor is between two and
three thousand pounds so that's deal
selling that's steel sourcing what's
coating sourcing coating sourcing is
when you do the same thing but this time
you don't need an investor list you
don't need if companies it's compliant
you don't need a reputation the only
thing you need is deals so you find a
deal and then you co source it with
someone who's compliant with someone
who's got an investor list with some of
this got a company so you approach
instead of approaching investors and
trying to flog a deal to investors you
approach up-and-running deal packaging
fans and there's loads of them there's
people that became compliant built of
that investor list they've got
everything all the ducks in a row
they just haven't got deals and I've got
a Facebook group with over 28,000
members and a lot of them are deal
sources with investors with companies
just without deals so a co deal saucer
is for you if you're really good at
finding property investment deals or you
know you've got the time to find deals
but you
haven't got the inclination to build an
investor list you haven't got the
compliant side of things so you're going
to find the deal you're going to
approach somebody who's got a deal
sourcing company already and you're
gonna say hey would you like this deal
to sell to your investors and if so
might these two thousand pounds and
that's what I want from the deal and
then they'll sell it for four thousand
pounds and you'll both make two thousand
pound each
very very simple this is just joint
venture most people in business most
people in property they've been forced
to joint venture and collaborate with
other people I collaborate people all
the time I've collaborated with kodiyal
sources I've collaborated with people
that find properties I put the money in
I collaborate where I've not put any
money in and like they've put the money
but I've got the deal collab when you
know how to collab when you know how to
code deal source when you know how to
joint venture when you know to network
what happens is suddenly everything
becomes possible people will tell you
you can't do that because you haven't
got the money you can't do that because
you haven't got the this or that or the
other well find someone that has got it
and collab all right this is how I grew
my YouTube channel in the early days I
collaborate with other youtubers you
garlis start collaborating so if you
look questions about kodiyal sauce think
about how it works
comment below and I will do a part two
and I'll answer all of your nitty-gritty
questions around coding your sourcing
but guys you've got to start networking
you've got to start putting yourself out
there and you've got to take massive
massive action so I hope you found this
video useful if you did smash the like
button turn on the notification bow and
drop a comment in the box below because
do you know how many how many theorists
right here you're on a theorist is a
theorist is someone that just talks they
talk about all the nitty-gritty I'm not
about that I'm about doing and I believe
when people watch my videos what happens
is they just start doing and that's why
there's so many people are successful as
my YouTube channel so if you want to
help spread the word if you want to help
more people become successful more
people become doers and implementers and
and becoming financially free and
successful in property then please do
you share this video and drop a comment
and smash the like button because more
people will see the video that is the
only thing I want from you thank you so
much for watching I'll see you next time
subscribe